Courtside of the game so just wanted to  get your thoughts on what he meant to  the culture and what he means to you too  as well  um  I'll be listening to those guys for so  long I was listening to those guys went  out my first year with the heat in 2010.  and you can ask any one of my teammates  back then they had no idea what Amigos  was  they were like cursing me out when I  would play it throughout the weight room  or playing throughout the locker room I  was like I'm telling you these guys are  next I'm letting you know right now  these days like turn this off I might  want to hear this  um  and just fast forward I mean just just  knowing  um you know take off personally and send  my condolences to cuevo and the family  and the whole  QC family and everybody  um it's just  um it's an